es ist ein sehr schöner hoffe es sehr
ruhig weil die der lärm der stadt nicht
nach oben bringen kann
aber es ist auch ein hochsicherheits
gebiet das heißt dort darf man nur mit
genehmigung
ansonsten sagt die bilanz hat die
vatikanische polizei und dann auch
spätestens die schweizergarde stoppt
hier geht es nicht weiter denn die
schweizergarde bewacht den papst ja die
schweizergarde bewachten mit hilfe der
gender maria der vatikan hat also ihnen
eine eigene polizeitruppe um die 100
leute auch die in blauen uniformen sind
und gemeinsam mit der schweizer garde
versehen die den wachdienst für den
papst und für den vatikan
es wird heute abend ja etwas optisches
geben womit das ende des pontifikats
dann doch signale sieht wird hier sehen
wir ein bild aus dem papstpalast platz
bendikt steigt aus dem
aus dem appartement oder das ist eine
tür die man eher nicht gewöhnt ist vom
appartement oh jetzt verabschiedet sich
von ihm kardinal comastri das ist der
erzpriester der petersbasilika und
rechts der vorher mit dem papst als
kardinal vallini der kardinal liga für
rom
die dame kenne ich nicht an der
seniorenresidenz der regent der kassa
ponti feature also der stellvertreter
von erzbischof denn 211 gänswein steht
hinter dem papst der zieht mit ihm jetzt
aus also ich weiß nicht ob sie wirklich
koffer packen mussten aber jetzt ist es
dann doch soweit der papst verlässt das
päpstliche appartement
palast
ungewohnte einblicke in diesem bereich
da dürfen normalerweise dürfen die
kamera sie nur in den offiziellen
audienz allen filmen und dass man sie
bis ins appartement lässt das wird wohl
nicht so schnell wieder geben
sie waren dort sicher schon öfter und
können beschreiben wo wir jetzt gerade
sind jetzt müsste auf die lotter gehen
wahrscheinlich zum aufzug nämlich an dem
schweizer garten vorbei
carina komas trete also auf der linken
seite zu sehen ist es als erste priester
sozusagen der hausherr der
petersbasilika also wenn der papst dort
zur eucharistiefeier hinkommt in die
petersbasilika dann wird er zunächst von
kardinal comastri begrüßt
dementsprechend die sind schon unten
sogar es sei auch an den ich danach aus
es wirkt nicht wie die wohnung des
platzes und jetzt geht es schon zur
seitlichen tür auf den damals hof dort
wo der wagen schon bereitsteht
und jetzt ist der moment gekommen
der papst
steht auf der schwelle der tür des
papstpalastes und verlässt damit seinen
ersten amtssitz
sind wir rechts kardinal bertone hinter
ihm erzbischof bett zu dass
verabschiedet sich kardinal bertone der
hat ihn als staatssekretär und dann ab
20 uhr der camerlengo also derjenige der
die geschicke des vatikans dann leiten
wird das jetzt ist erzbischof dass das
substitut der stellvertreter des
staatssekretärs erzbischof mamberti der
sekretär für die angelegenheiten mit den
staaten der welt der assessor der
stellvertreter die kenne ich jetzt nicht
sind mitarbeiter des
finanzstaatssekretärs ist unser diese
kriterien
von kardinal bertone und von erzbischof
es ist ein denkwürdiges bild denn
das ist ein
moment den man sich ein paar hundert
jahren nicht hat vorstellen können
ja und auch nicht vorstellen wollen auch
das dass ein papst lebend das amt
verlässt
und auch dem vatikan verlässt
in einen wagen steigt
dann mit einem hubschrauber mit quasi
aus dem angriff logen zu werden ja
noch ein letztes wieder noch für ein
letztes mal ein segen für die
angestellten vom staatssekretariat und
dem palast wer immer dort überhaupt auf
den hof durfte ja
kennst du die zeremonie zum teil
das noch einmal in eine deutsche
neben beschenkt wurde einige wagen
beschränkt
star ausgestattet mit
allerlei was einem
älteren herren vielleicht auch ganz gut
tut und die reisen erleichtert natürlich
wir sehen hier gepanzert und
jetzt geht es schon los
der weg ist sehr kurzen
aber ein abgeschirmter abgesperrter weg
mit ihm fährt monsignore gänswein sein
privatsekretär und nach perfektes
plötzlichen hauses
den weg heraus aus dem damals hoch noch
einmal an der schweizer gerade vorbei
die bis zum 8 uhr noch bewachen wird und
dann zum zeichen des ende des
pontifikats
den dienst beendet und abgezogen wird
und die mitarbeiter können das kaum
fassen
der arzt ist weg
jetzt noch über den marsch als hof
vorbei
an der sixtinischen kapelle dort wo das
für ihn begann das pontifikat ja sagte
ich nehme die wahl an
die jetzt über ihn ist die sixtinische
kapelle und als er sagte ich möchte
papst benedikt der sechzehnte heißen
jetzt schlängelt sich die straße ein
wenig hinauf wir sehen uns hier am
petersdom vorbei die kleine kirche sankt
stephan
jetzt fertig gerade an dem brunnen
vorbei der erste wagen den hat er
anlegen lassen da sind szenen aus dem
leben des heiligen josef also da hatte
eine spur hinterlassen im vatikan sieht
man jetzt oben sind solche bronzereliefs
mit den wichtigsten stationen des
heiligen josef franzl hofft dass ghana
kurator der zivilverwaltung
des vatikans
scv 1 dass jetzt das nummernschild für
stato della città del vaticano
das ist das nummernschild was immer
dieses auto trägt in dem dann herbst
sitzt wie sonst kein wagen und das wird
nicht immer um montiert sondern alle
fragen die für den herbst vorgesehen
sind hier sehen den und schon um das
gpotato herumfahren
alle waagen haben dieses scv 1 es gibt
auch ein paar papa mobile und davon gibt
es eine ganze reihe die haben sogar
andere nummern also 345 gibt es zum
beispiel jetzt kommt er damals fast dort
vorbei wo er demnächst auch wohnen wird
das sind die gewesen anders ist das haus
genau man sieht noch den den bau aufzugs
und seht ja schuld herunter geschüttet
wird ja das gelblich wirkende in der
sonne stehende haus zeigt dass die
letztlich die alt päpstliche wohnung
dann schöne abendsonne haben wird und
dieser kleine garten denen die
schwestern gepflegt haben und immer
schön das gemüse angepflanzt wird ihnen
dann als kleiner wahrscheinlich sehr
private auslauf zur verfügung stehen so
weite wege
wird er nicht mehr schaffen das hat man
in der letzten zeit immer sehen können
es ist ja schon fast am heliport
oben noch einmal
die burg mit radio vatikan
ganz in der nähe die große sendeantenne
kann man noch erkennen wir mit
zumindest vor die tore von rom gesendet
wird und dann von dort aus die stimme
des papstes so nennt sich radio radio
vatikan die drehbar ist und in alle welt
hinaus sendet egal wohin
durch die vatikanischen gärten
hinter dem
zugleich haben
heliport an
das ist der äußersten zipfel ja der
vatikanstadt ja eine spitze eine wehr
spitze die
aufgeschüttet ist in teilen denn der
vatikan ist eigentlich ein hügel der hat
dort an dieser stelle noch eine gewisse
höhe aber das hat man an der stelle noch
ein wenig aufgeschüttet eine der
höchsten stellen innerhalb der
vatikanstadt und der wagen ist schon
angekommen hubschrauberlandeplatzes
fahrt kurze wege bei nur einem halben
quadratkilometer größe da ist das
vorprogrammiert und als papst hat man
vorfahrt abschied von kardinal sogar
norden ja kardinaldekan
per e mail
ersten momente seiner amtszeit noch als
kardinalstaatssekretär diente kardinal
lajolo wer früher nur in deutschland war
und danach im staatssekretariat
beziehungsweise als gouverneur des
vatikanstaates gedient hatte setzten
zwischen den funktionen
traditionell begrüßt
die noten
noch einmal ein blick wieder hingewiesen
dass sind die das kleine seminar von rom
ist gegenüber haben vielleicht die
schrift gesehen graz spot und vergelt's
gott glaube ich stand da das ist das
vorbereitungsseminar der diözese rom
standen einige auf dem dach ist beginnt
die priesterausbildung der distanz
kandidaten von rom
so jetzt verlässt der papst
als papst als amtierende papst
vatikanischen boten ja und steigt in den
hubschrauber ein
wir werden live dabei bleiben das
vatikanische fernsehen city bildet
bietet diese bilder an
denn das sind die
seminar oder vor seminaristen roms haben
sich noch einige andere wohl auch dazu
gesellt
die diesen privilegierten aussichtspunkt
gerne nutzen wollen um noch einmal um
heimsieg auf den abschied zu werfen
so sind alle an bord wie es aussieht
das ist eine relativ gelöste stimmung
kann man feststellen
angeschnallt
richtig
uns liegen zwar ein herz bischof
gänswein ist doch für solche
kleinen
handgriffe immer da gewesen
das muss man als sekretär auch tun ja
das wasser reichen hier
oder den papst an gurten
jetzt geht die reise 30 kilometer
luftlinie in die albaner berge das schon
relativ kurzer flug also zehn minuten
die kameras werden dabei bleiben von
einem zweiten hubschrauber das
dass ein vertikaler das noch nicht weiß
das haben wir nicht bestellte wir sind
froh dass es ihnen liefern können zu
hause meine damen und herren dass das
vatikanische fernsehen das anbietet und
dass monsanto graulich den eigentlich
den hubschrauber eigentlich von seinem
fenster aus sehen wollte ihn jetzt hier
bei uns sehen kann
auf dem weg nach castelgandolfo meine
damen und herren das ist der moment
nicht das ende des pontifikates das wird
heute abend um 20 uhr stattfinden wir
werden das hier live berichten aus rom
aber das ist der endgültige moment des
weggangs aus der vatikanstadt von papst
benedikt
seit über 30 jahren
in rom und wird wohl noch ein paar jahre
in rom verbringen
wir wünschen ritus
weil es dann doch wohl nur der liebe
gott wie lange und in welcher verfassung
es schwankt ein bisschen die bilder die
wir gesehen haben sie waren sehr
ambivalenz teilweise wirkte er sehr alt
und müde in den letzten tagen auch heute
die ist produkt von sankt peter leuten
zum abschied auch ungewöhnlich weil
normalerweise
ja auch zu anderen natürlich auch zur
freudigen anlässen aber auch zu
traurigen anlässen
die glocken läuten das immer die glocken
jetzt sagen wollen sie gehören jetzt
dazu
größen s heute abend auch noch ein
geläut 24 zum ende des pontifikats zum
beginn der sedisvakanz
gut
einer darf noch mit und dann ist
der hubschrauber ist startbereit
man hatte erwartet dass der abschied
noch sehr viel nüchterner ausfallen
würde
das sind doch so viele dabei sein
durften auf dem damals hof vatikan
angestellte mitarbeiter des
staatssekretariats
und des palastes
eine schöne geste
ganz so nüchtern wollte man es dann doch
vielleicht nicht vonstatten gehen lassen
heute vormittag auch der abschied
kardinälen
herz der metallen die anwesend sind
und der moment ist da
der papst befindet sich nicht mehr in
der vatikanstadt jetzt
im hubschrauber der automatisch sobald
der papst ihn betritt exterritoriales
gebiet ist genauso wie ein auto
oder das papamobil wir sehen sogar
menschen die auf den dächern sind und
winken
jetzt hoffen wir wir schauen auch hier
schon nach hinten ob wir ihn schon sehen
können helikopter über den petersdom
rausfliegen
noch einmal die menschen grüßen so war
es jedenfalls vorgesehen aber es sieht
so aus als würde er schon früher
abbiegen älter werden wir ihn von hier
aus nicht einmal sehen können das heißt
der überflug der eventuell angedacht war
über den anlass platz sehr teuer
viele schon weg er wurde offenbar
eingespart gestrichen vielleicht wollte
man
doch nicht so viel
ein party in das ganze herein geben alle
die jetzt in rom sind in der ewigen
stadt und zum himmel blicken sehen den
hubschrauber den kennt man hier den
weißen hubschrauber man weiß wenn der
hier über die stadt fliegt es entweder
ein übungsflug um den flug mit dem papst
zu üben wie in den letzten tagen schon
öfters und auch heute schon mehrfach
oder es setzt der papst im hubschrauber
aber das wissen die römer in der regel
schon ganz gut
wann ein papst nach castel gandolfo oder
auf dem flughafen fliegt
manche schicken fleisch nach einem
gebiet mit hoher und sagen
graz benedetto so wie es die stadt rom
auch getan hat mit plakaten
auf den plakaten steht du wirst immer
bei uns sein immer mit uns sein
und ein dickes dankeschön
ein brunnen gewohnte dienst hat gern
das papstes
bilder eines hubschraubers die weltweit
übertragen werden jetzt sehen wir noch
einmal deutschland doch noch eine runde
liegt er über den vertikal über den
vatikan geflogen zu sein um den vatikan
denn die sendeantenne von radio vatikan
hat ist dann doch deutlich gemacht und
jetzt müssen wir ihn fast hier sehen
jetzt liegt er über uns meine damen und
herren wir hören ihn
nicht so
nun direkt überflogen worden vom
heiligen vater von papst benedikt dem
sechzehnten
und er fliegt jetzt
heraus
aus der stadt also dann doch noch eine
ehrenrunde eine größere als erwartet
jetzt sehen wir noch einmal blicken
tiefer entlang
in tiefer
von christoph
gleich kommt die tiefe sondern
sein persönlich letzter hubschrauberflug
sein wird das mag dahingestellt bleiben
wahrscheinlich schon denn man kann auch
mit dem auto von castel gandolfo her
herüberkommen und wahrscheinlich wird
man es genau so halten dass man ihn in
aller stille und wahrscheinlich auch
verschwiegenheit und heimlichkeit her
bringen wird so dass es eben keinen
großen auflauf gibt kein großes
interesse
die spanische treppe noch einmal fast
schon wie eine zwar nicht die spanische
treppe nein wir sehen das forum romanum
capitol ja richtig dass leptin jetzt
forum romanum kolosseum dann gleich
richtig der industrie um einen
vorbeiflug am kolosseum wahrscheinlich
wird am lateran dann nach seiner
bischofskirche
vorbeifliegen noch einmal wieder schauen
sagen von der unterrichtung wird ist das
ungefähr so müssten der gleich im bild
haben die lateran basilika san giovanni
in laterano und den alten papstpalast
der nicht mehr von päpsten bewohnt wird
aber doch einmal im jahr sozusagen
heimgesucht wird am japan fest da sehen
wir schon den alten palast unter seliger
dass er die passanten in laterano
die eigentliche bischofskirche des
papstes in seiner eigenschaft als
bischof von rom
vorher dann zumindest am gründonnerstag
auch die liturgie feiert
und auch sonst einmal in einem seminar
zu gast ist
und wenn es besondere anlässe gibt die
ihn dahin führen
es wäre jetzt fast ein bisschen
verwunderlich wenn er alle papst kirchen
denn es gibt ja noch ein paar mehr die
sehr wichtig sind in rom abfliegen würde
aber die haben wir gelernt in den
letzten tagen
dieser papst ist manchmal für
überraschungen gut eben auch für diesen
tag mit dem man so zwar rechnen konnte
aber dann doch irgendwie nicht so
wirklich aktiv gerechnet hat die
überraschung war gelungen
wie ist das so im
bei ihnen unter den kollegen
diskutiert worden in den vergangenen
tagen
der rücktritt und diese doch relativ
schnelle abgang so schnell wasser dann
auch nicht zwischen ankündigung und
tatsächlich vakant sind wir haben 17
tage vergangen
immerhin hier also man konnte sich dann
doch vorbereiten aber es war vieles
nicht vorbereitet
viele dinge sind auch immer noch nicht
klar
es ist natürlich eine große
wertschätzung für diesen schritt denn
was politik gegangen ist und
denn er sich sicher gut überlegt hat
und zugleich kommen auch einige
befürchtungen auf
was jetzt werden wir gerät erneuerbar
pflicht unter druck auch ein solcher
schritt zu setzen und so weiter sind
immer sehr viele überlegungen im gange
wie wird es weitergehen und was wird
jetzt mit dem nächsten papst passieren
was wird mit ihm passieren was heute
passieren lassen dass es vor allen
dingen die frage also das ist schon fast
eine flugshow die hier in rom geboten
wird im leichten abend nebeldunst das
sieht man jetzt die peters kuppel
nochmal von weiter weg - aber das ist
der smog über der stadt liegt so dicht
wie da sieht man nicht mehr sehr viel
dafür wird in den albaner bergen dann
umso schöner
umso klarer die luft ist frisch dass es
auch ein grund warum die päpste der
zweimal sehr gerne hinaufgehen es ist im
sommer nicht zu heiß und die frische
luft von den alltag vom albaner see die
nach oben weht ist in der regel relativ
frisch und kühl
und das wird jetzt ein winter sitz
das ja ich nehme regiert das nicht ein
sommersitz also das wird ein bisschen um
deklariert ein vorübergehender winter
sitz ist dann friere die appia entlang
die wir als stadt die alte straße die
alte das aquädukt für das wasser mit
nach rom gebracht wurde
also wir machen hier noch einen bild
spaziergang fast schon touristischer art
den uns der papst beschert wir sehen
schon da ist der himmel schon wieder
etwas blauer wer das näher
sicherheitsstand insel ist autobahn und
schon bald in richtung mehr in richtung
mittelmeer geht es grob gesagt
sankt peter läutet noch immer jetzt wird
vielleicht sogar solange leuten bis der
touchdown also die landesstraße aus
castel gandolfo vermeldet wird bei den
modernen medien heutzutage sitzt
wahrscheinlich der mensch der die
glocken schalter unter den fingern hat
am fernseher und kann alles live mit
verfolgen so wie sie meine damen und
herren zu hause
in diesem fall können wir wirklich
einmal
vollumfänglich und gänzlich das ganze
bild zeigen bei phoenix ich freue mich
dass wir
kontinuierlich und ingo brüggenjürgen
auch hier haben zum kommentieren
dieser letzten stunden ja man kann schon
fast sagen dieser letzten minuten von
papst benedikt hingebogen jürgen wenn
sie das jetzt sehen
also es ist beeindruckend ich finde es
sehr schön dass die kollegen vom city wo
vom vatikanischen fernsehens diese
bilder hier ermöglichen
und es gibt ja ein immenses
medieninteresse in aller welt wer hier
in den letzten tagen war konnte sehen
wie viele medienvertreter aus allen
ländern da sind die natürlich diese
bilder gern ihren zuschauern überall in
der welt liefern wollen viele wollen
eben dabei sein und es auch toll dass
die kollegen solche tollen bildern
bieten auch allein unter historischen
aber auch unterziehen gesichtspunkten
das sagt der radiomann der auch von
bildern lebt ja und dieses pontifikat
lebt auch von bildern die wir gar nicht
so erwartet hatten
denn wer einen joseph ratzinger kannte
wusste dass er ein sehr zurückhaltend im
interessiert schon der flughafen
ciampino überflogen der alte römische
flughafen und es ist zeit mich zu
auslandsreisen aufgebrochen
dort stieß dort genannte eventuell dann
mit dem auto weiter
jetzt schon wieder den flughafen also
zumindest die reale wo normalerweise der
helikopter gelandet wäre aber sieht
wirklich danach aus also wir sind dann
scheint doch wieder mit überraschungen
bedacht worden
also es könnte tatsächlich sein
das hatte man bisher im palast nicht
verlauten lassen das ist doch eine
längere reise noch wird nämlich
minütlich länger aber er steigt gerade
wieder sich spanien steigt wieder auf
also dann doch keine landung auf dem
flughafen ciampino denn nicht weit ist
von castel gandolfo aber mit dem auto
wäre es dann doch noch fast hätte man
auch die ganze strecke die fahrstrecke
sperren müssen also man kann auch im
gelände von castel gandolfo landen
da gibt es ja weiter gärten ein riesen
park ist sogar mit einer brücke mit dem
eigentlichen gelände verbunden
diese brücke darf nur der papst und
diejenigen die zugelassen sind dafür
es gibt einen tierpark
in dem vor allen dingen
oder nicht vor allen dingen aber auch
tiere leben
die johannes paul ii geschenkt bekommen
hat er gerade mal die landebahn gesehen
also das was willst wir ihnen als bild
liefern beweist auch wenn der papst
überfliegt ist der luftraum gesperrt
die älteste kino kino darf noch fliegen
aber der alte flughafen der vor allen
dingen von lok austrian airlines
angeflogen wird von es gibt noch
militärischen teil auch und vom militär
ist jetzt für kurze zeit still gelegt
das ist die reminiszenz an papst
benedikt
das werden die fluggäste verkraften
können jetzt ist es nicht mehr weit
kuba muss noch ein bisschen steigen denn
es geht doch schon relativ steilen
zürich ja ja eben es auf der höhe der
residenz ist
wir
dritten hubschrauber
erstaunlich dass wir die residenz chance
also gibt es den hubschrauber in dem die
kamera sind dann gibt es nach einem
begleit hubschrauber und den
hubschrauber des papstes ich glaube das
sind schon bilder aus dem anflug
vielleicht fangen die kameras die in
castel gandolfo positioniert wenn den
anfliegenden helikopter hier schon ein
oder so wir werden
vielleicht nicht erfahren wir werden nur
diesen hubschrauber diesen weißen
planten sehen und der papst wird
aussteigen wird begrüßt dort castel
gandolfo vom ortsbürgermeister vom
ortsbischof der allerdings nicht in
castelgandolfo und diesem kleinen
städtchen residiert sondern albano
alban
das ist
ein ort weiter weg glaube ich von
constantin ort weiter zwischen ist nur
was kleines noch
die stadt ist gar nicht groß da wohnen
gar nicht so viele menschen die sind
ganz stolz darauf dass bei ihm ab und zu
einer der einwohner ihr herbst ist
obwohl man sagen muss auch castel
gandolfo ist exterritoriales also
vatikanisches gebiet und gehört damit
eigentlich nicht zur stadt aber dennoch
sind
alle einwohner stolz wenn er dann doch
im sommer einige wochen hier
dort verbringt der empfängt die auch
immer nachher dann den bürgermeister das
macht personal also ablauf eine gute
beziehung feiert mit der gemeinde dort
das fest der aufnahme mariens in den
himmel in der pfarrkirche also die
kirmes sozusagen mit dem papst das
hätten
manche gemeinden in der welt gerne das
sind schon tatsächlich jetzt bilder auch
unter schutz stehenden kamera von castel
gandolfo
die kameras haben den helikopter des
platzes jetzt klein im bild
ernährt sich seiner vorübergehenden
residenz und ernährt sich auch zeitlich
dem ende des pontifikats ja
20 uhr ist es so weit vorher wird er
aber noch mal ans fenster kommen um auf
dem kleinen balkon der residenz nach
draußen zum platz wie es heißt oder
leicht nach innen zum innenhof
das ist in europa sind noch einmal ganz
kurz zu den menschen sprechen
sich verabschieden und das werden dann
definitiv die letzten bilder von papst
benedikt dem sechzehnten sein denn den
beginn der sedisvakanz und den endpunkt
des konten des pontifikats
werden lediglich die schweizergardisten
anzeigen die dann ihren dienst beenden
und abgezogen werden
mit einem kurzen wachwechsel in der
weise
dass die wache beendet wird denn die
schweizergardisten bewachen nur den
amtierenden papst und seine gemächer
nähert er sich schon den dortigen
hubschrauberlandeplatz in den gärten
es ist idyllisch studieren in diesem
parkanlagen
es gibt eine fast terrasse die nur von
pinien gesund ist
auf der der papst sehr gerne ab und zu
gesessen hat im gras mit einem ganz
schlichten hölzernen gartentisch also
wirklich nur gartenmöbel und sich bücher
mitgenommen hatten dort zu lesen in der
nachmittagssonne im halbschatten hier
sehen wir schon die parkanlage in castel
gandolfo
die glocken von st peter leute nach
leuten noch
in rom geht das dann auch immer sehr
schnell das können wir jetzt schon
feststellen
man geht über zum alltag in castel
gandolfo kommt jetzt erst einmal die
nummer eins in mode uno wie er genannt
wird der papst an
seine letzten
zweieinhalb stunden im amt und
er ist
mit den vorderrädern auf dem boden
sicher angekommen auch immer richtig hat
vor allen dingen die italienische
regierung auch immer große sorge dass
sind papst unterwegs etwas passieren
könnte
und dass man eventuell dafür
verantwortlich gemacht werden könnte
also immer ein heikler akt so ähnlich
wie beim amerikanischen präsidenten
die sicherheitsstufen
präsidenten und den herbst sind weltweit
identisch
und daher kommt schon fahrzeug
herbst flaggen als standard
um
seine heiligkeit benedikt den
sechzehnten als passagier zu übernehmen
jetzt sind noch ein paar meter kann man
sagen zu fahren man sich dort die
wirtschaftsgebäude da gibt es auch keine
einen guten gemüseanbau ökologischer
gemüseanbau für den papst das was wir
sehen sieht nicht nach weil rauch aus
auch nicht nach weißem rauch den wir in
der sixtinischen kapelle erwarten
sondern das sind die motoren
das schauen was im harz benedikt ist an
ort und stelle selbst
die feuerwehr es angetreten für
eventualitäten
jetzt kommt es zur begrüßung
durch das personal vor ort
der papst bedankt sich in der regel
immer nach jedem flug bei seinem piloten
sind die kameras werden noch schnell
herangeschleppt
so können wird schlecht sehen wer jetzt
da wir werden das gleich sehen wer ihnen
da begrüßt die kamera ist ja schon im
aufbau und es wird man sicherlich noch
wenige augenblicke dauern und sie ist
auf rot geschaltet unter sind wir schon
ja das typische von kastel gern also von
abano simmerath denn aus seinem
auf seinem gebiet ja
es müsste der bürgermeister
müsste man erkennt man die schärfe hat
das sind auch keine back tory und sascha
k der gouverneur und der sekretär der
vatikanstadt die nicht verabschiedet
haben sondern gehen dann eben in castel
gandolfo begrüßt
wer bleibt jetzt mit dem papst in castel
gandolfo
wer seine sekretärin
und wahrscheinlich sind dann auch die
mails die in den haushalt geführt haben
die lieder für ihn gekocht haben wir
auch weiterhin werden dort auch
weiterhin für ihn trocken werden und sie
kardinal sektor der gouverneur
und es ist noch immer so ein
bild man sieht den lächeln wirkt relativ
gelöst auch eingeräumt
man kann kaum glauben dass das jetzt die
abschieds bilder sind ein paar der
ruhestand geht
wer sein pontifikat beendet ingo
brüggenjürgen tja ein historischer
moment und wir können hier auch noch mal
wieder gut erkennen
er macht das protokollarisch alles
korrekt da liegen alle ihr wert drauf da
wird nichts ausgelassen aber
gleichzeitig glaube ich wird auch jedem
zuschauer deutlich wie viele
verpflichtungen mit einem solchen amt
immer verbunden sind wie viele hände zu
schütteln gilt und wer möglichst immer
ganz nah an den heiligen vater dann
möchte ich fühle da ein bisschen mit ihm
und glaube er wird sich freuen die ihnen
das jetzt in wenigen stunden erspart
bleibt und wenn er wieder ein stück
zurück in das private leben tauchen kann
wir sehen wieder scv einst als
nummernschild also immer das aktuelle
fahrzeug in dem der papst fährt und nur
der papst fahren darf
mit dem
nummernschild das anzeigt wer der
passagier ist das andere
wir hier in rom in italien vor allen
dingen auch
vatikan genannt wird so als antiker und
jetzt geht es diese kleine fahrstraße
die relativ schnurstracks mit einer
leichten übung auf den asphalt zu führt
man sehr schöner spaziergang braucht man
wenn man das alles umrunden will gut und
gerne eine halbe stunde des geländes
größer als die vatikanstadt zehnmal
größer ungefähr
aber es ist dennoch
nicht so weit meine damen und herren das
ist natürlich wunderbar deswegen hier
mit den bildern vom vatikanischen
fernsehen so einen eindruck einmal
liefern können einen tägliches
kaleidoskop
dessen was man sonst wirklich nicht zu
sehen bekommt
die parkanlagen von castelgandolfo die
von gärtnern liebevoll gepflegt werden
vielleicht sehen wir auch noch die
residenz etwas besser die drei alten
gebäude die aneinander gebaut sind auch
die päpstlichen sternwarte ist dort eine
weltweit hoch beachtete sternwarte in
der
große wissenschaftler arbeiten im
auftrag des vatikans in zusammenarbeit
mit allen großen instituten der welt
ja
es gibt einen
teil des gebäudes und den offiziellen
räumlichkeiten untergebracht sind für
empfänger einen sehr großen saal für
audienzen die ein papst auch abhält wenn
er in der sommerpause ist obwohl da das
programm natürlich deutlich reduziert
ist
einige kleinere säle für empfänge und
begegnungen dann gibt es einen
gebäudeteil der er privat ist mit einem
kleinen fast schon unscheinbaren aufzug
der hinauf führt in die etage in dem der
papst an wohnt wenn er in castelgandolfo
ist und sich dort aufhält
die räume sind alle etwas niedriger als
im herbst palast auch kleiner als wir im
vatikan hinter uns auch ein bisschen der
fast schon ländlicher sie haben etwas
von einem
land
gut einem land schloss
nicht von der großen kracht
klasse des vatikans
dass die fahrt länger sk10 die karten
farbe
ja das kann man
möglich erkennen und jetzt geht es aber
schon
die toreinfahrt die seitliche tor
nicht
auf dem hof und das ist schon der
bereich wo es nach links
b
die gemächer geht's uns
rechts dann den privaten teil
hat
jetzt relativ schnell
den blicken schwinden vielleicht noch
mal einen blick
kamera haben
wenn ihn sein
er macht darauf hinweist hinter diesen
schmiedeeisernen
mit dieser schmiede also eine tür mit
glas
beginnt dann
der bereich
das passt so dass
der platz ist gut gefüllt vor der auf
der platte sind ist eine menge
versammelt um dem papst noch einmal zu
sehen man sich sehr schön den innenhof
in denen dann kleinere generalaudienzen
abgehalten werden
mit der neuen überdachung damit es nicht
zu heiß wird wenn die sonne
was steht denn zu zeiten
eine fast senkrechte drittens da gab es
schon einige kleine
hitze unfälle
dieser platz
verstehst an die
str
kleinstadt zu sehen
weiter unten sind noch ein paar straßen
und dann
häuser
war das im grunde
die alte stadt das egal
sie sehen sehr schön die gebäude und
auch die sternwarte die kuppel der
sternwarte
wenn man sehen zwei kuppeln gibt es
insgesamt nicht sehen konnten
berichtigte swimmingpool das papst
johannes paul geschenkt wurde
das über papst benedikt so
niemals aufgesucht hat also dieser papst
ist jedenfalls nicht
bester gandolfo baden gegangen
jedenfalls
nicht immer sehen wir noch ein letztes
mal das päpstliche machen
trotzdem
vorhandene über die brüstung des balkons
braucht wunderschöne alternative
kann verstehen dass ich auch benedikt
dort immer sehr wohl gefühlt
ein sehr schöner ort auch immer
wesentlich kleiner als rom
helmut ausgewählt werden diese stadt
lebt natürlich ein bisschen
und alle die gekommen
sie sehen jetzt für den herbst
später fuhr am militärflughafen
praktisch nur größer gemacht
häufiger gesehen
transparenten
letzten angelus gebet oder bei der
generalaudienz dabei
wir hören gerade einen gesang aber es
hört sich an als würde man nur benedetto
singen aber so vielstimmig als wäre es
ein großer chor
wir sind gespannt
wie diese letzte begegnung mit den
menschen die es aus fahren wird das ist
dann aber auch tatsächlich die letzte
begegnung mit den gläubigen als papst
erst dann hier auf dem petersplatz
gerade generalaudienz die
großveranstaltung jetzt nach anderen
kleinen dann definitiv auch die letzten
bilder vom pontifex
benedikt
er wird sich dann in seine
privatgemächer zurückziehen wie man ihn
kennt
abendessen
entwickeln
ganz dicht
und ergreifend
und dann um 20 uhr fällt
vielleicht eine last von ihm
ein kreuz das er
weiter trägt was er gestern gesagt
aber jetzt in privaten e
die menschen sind benedetto etwas
dass er sich erst gewöhnen muss die
gewinnzunahme
seit das von den menschen gerufen wird
ganz von johannes paul im zweiten jahr
auch gewöhnt war
über eine paulo und hier dieses
benedetto und auch wurde auch ein
letztes mal
denn wir werden ihnen wohl alle nicht
mehr zu gesicht bekommen
ein paar fotos wenn das alles so
stattfinden wird wie es vorgesehen ist
aber es
deutet sich auch an das hat er selber
auch angedeutet dass er sich tatsächlich
heraus halten belassen
geschäften und den nächsten papst
nichts kaputt machen möchte vor allem
auch der kirche damit nichts kaputt
machen möchte
er hatte auch den kardinälen heute
morgen gesagt dass er dem neuen park
schon jetzt seinen gehorsam verspricht
das war auch eindeutig dass er sich gar
nicht mehr ein
das geschäft sehr wichtig diese
formulierung
gebracht hat dass ein zurückgetretener
papst dem neuen papst
im gehorsam gegenüber verpflichtet da
steht und weiter liegt gar noch
deutlicher formuliert von
bedingungslosen gehorsam gesprochen und
das finde ich macht wiederum sehr
deutlich worum es hier geht er tritt
wirklich zurück er wird seiner kirche im
gebet und meditation dienen die bilder
die wir gleich sehen werden wenn meines
erachtens die bilder seien
die wirklich vom papst den allerletzten
rotterdam sind
aber er wird nicht essen sondern ich
denke er wird die letzten stunden
sicherlich auch noch mal im gebet diesen
schweren schritt erleben wir sind das
schöne aufnahmen einer der hoch
fotografen in der residenz des papstes
und da ist auch schon der balkon
statt in der lage
der könnte es sich theoretisch jetzt
noch mal überlegen
theoretisch ja
aber wer das nicht tue also bis 20 uhr
ich bin glücklich hier mit euch zu sein
umgeben von der schönheit der natur von
ihrer zuneigung die mir sehr gut tut
danke für eure zuneigung für
freundschaft ihr wisst dass dieser tag
heute anders ist als die anderen tage
ich bin nicht mehr der papst der kirche
nun bis 8 uhr noch aber danach nicht
mehr
ich bin danach der die letzte etappe
seiner pilgerreise auf dieser erde
beginnt
dekan johann ich möchte noch einmal mit
meinem herzen mit meinem gebet mit
meinen überlegungen mit all meinen
kräften für das wohl der kirche und der
menschheit arbeiten leben beten und ich
fühle mich sehr getragen von eurer
zuneigung geben die miteinander voran
für das wohl der kirche und der welt
noch einmal danke von herzen
die titel call me up edition und von
ganzem herzen möchte ich euch segnen
gott der herr segne euch ihr vater der
sohn und der heilige geist
danke und gute nacht
vielen vielen dank an euch alle